all right bring in the next Pizza bring
in the pies ah damn everything here is
going crazy
peace Awards is back baby and you know
what that means if you're somebody's
into pizza if you're somebody's into
spicy food both of these pizzas smack
more
more with your heart if you don't do
anything with your heart there's no
value there's no meaning to anything you
do it's not just pizza it's life I've
been training like crazy in the off
season and I can't wait for you to see
what we've been cooking up damn this
season we're cranking up the heat with
some seriously spicy slices oh it's hot
it's Slam Dancing Blown Away by the
pizza Blown Away a little bit by the
heat I don't know who made this but this
ain't thinking are we on the wrong show
is this hot ones changing the game by
leveling up Frozen Pies yeah
I love Red Baron I'm taking stuffed
crust pizza to outrageous New Heights we
wanted this stuff Crush we made this
stuff Crossing this is what the kids
love I love it it's all I love here but
of course I'll be facing off against my
toughest opponents yet and serving up
slices to some of your favorite
celebrity judges and pizza experts I was
expecting it not to be a thing
we should see the contestants so that we
can see their anguish and defeat and
there are no losers today someone's
going to leave here to today a champion
in this competition chill chill chill
chill it's just about pizza I'm on my
way to becoming a master pizza maker and
nothing could stop me now looks
beautiful I think I'm gonna take this
competition looks good peace Awards
season four is here get ready this is
outstanding
the best see you next time on pizza wars